[Music]
- one what's up everyone welcome to
simulation happy Climate Action Week
this week in San Francisco we are going
to be talking to Lachlan arts about his
project 2020 or bust taking climate
action thank you for coming out of the
show really really great thank you and
this is a great this is not only a great
important week here in San Francisco on
climate action and actually taking that
action moving forward yeah but it's also
one of the most pressing issues of our
time is figuring out sustainability
longevity long jeopardy first
civilization yes yeah you know you've
been doing this for three years three
years yes so not as long as many of the
people who are gonna be at the
conference but still three years yeah
yeah and you're you take a you take a
very action-oriented position absolutely
yeah yeah I crucial well I mean the only
thing that is gonna make the difference
is action yep you know the debates don't
make any difference you know the you
know the glaciers don't care what people
think about it you know it's just all
the debates and the blah blah blah you
know all that matters is action what got
us into this mess is action and what's
going to get us out of action yeah and
then the action that you're giving is
very oriented towards individuals
changing their behaviors it is and it
also about some of that action well you
came up with well the the initial shock
that I got was when I had conversations
with people who colleagues that I'd had
in previous work that I'd done who were
now at the United Nations and working
you know pretty high up and climate
change and when I asked him how long we
had until the
you know crap hits the fan they said
well it's probably already too late and
and they were serious and that was three
years ago and so anyway that thing that
really burned me is that most of the
population has no idea the reality of
the situation and are basically walking
around like well yeah I think so there
is definitely a problem and yeah there's
some connection between this and the
fires that are happening and the
flooding and the Hurricanes and you know
but you know it's somehow just gonna
work out or somebody's taking care of it
the United Nations the Paris Accord you
know the billionaire's the you know big
scientists somebody's somebody's taking
care of it and when you actually go into
the situation go to the conference's
talk to these people you really find out
that's not happening it's not happening
and there is a real aversion to actually
having the straight conversation called
you know we're screwed
not like a negative thing but we're
screwed right and unless we really start
to do some dramatic things different
than how it's currently going we're not
going to end up where anybody wants to
go and so that rules really where you
know the first thing that that we said
was is that if you're on the planet
regardless of your education regardless
of your ethnicity regardless of where
you live whatever you have the right to
know what's happening because this is
your planet and now if you say I see
what's happening and I don't care you
know like some people say hey you know
it's I'm gonna I'm gonna be gone before
the you know gets real bad so whatever
you know fine okay don't do anything but
you should have the right to do
something if you want to do something
and right now where we're headed is that
in about 20 years when it's obvious you
know when stuff really starts happening
when much of Miami has started to go
underwater not just flooding you know
when it's like when it becomes
undeniable for people to ignore anymore
hmm people are gonna say why didn't
somebody tell us and so it wasn't only
that everybody has the right to know
what's happening but if you want to do
something about actually ending it not
just making progress not just mitigate
you know not just you know adapting if
you really want to make a difference in
ending it you should have that
opportunity and so that's what you know
kind of made us the aliens in the room
because nobody was talking about ending
it and the the kind of general consensus
is is that whatever it's going to take
it's way too big for individuals so
that's when we went to work and we've
got these great scientists on our team
now and you know people from the UN and
very very credible people that kind of
you know thought we were crazy in the
right kind of way worked with us and
actually came up with the excuse me the
science of what it's going to take to
end at what that actually looks like and
actually worked a way that individuals a
lot individuals 500 million but still
you know one out of every 14 people on
the planet right now actually can take
the specific actions in the window of
opportunity that we have which is about
two years but if we take those actions
in that window we will go from a very
very bad future to a good shot at a
decent one so that's why we are out to
get the word out that we got two years
to get our crap together and you know
you do have the power to make an impact
and if you take these actions this is
actually what's going to happen yes so
we're looking at about a 2 degrees
Celsius temperature increase that's
right and that is over that is by 2020
ish well the deal is see that that and
it's you know generally agreed that that
if we can keep our you know when that
really when this when it really started
to accelerate the temper the temperature
really started to accelerate in terms of
the rise was in the Industrial
Revolution it you know makes perfect
sense all of a sudden we're emitting all
this carbon in the atmosphere that
wasn't happening before the Industrial
Revolution and we're talking about
humans say exactly right so if we can
keep our warming to a maximum of two
degree increase and then start to
decline it's somewhat safe okay
right now we just crossed the 1 degree
increase so we're already at 1 degrees
with the carbon that's already in the
atmosphere because it's because it stays
there for hundreds of years we'll
absolutely even if we stopped emitting
everything today we would go to another
point 3 degree warming so out of the two
degree window we view we're at one point
three so we've only got a point seven
degree window left so and again we just
want to get that out to the general
public it's not good it's not bad it's
just this is the deal and you know we've
got it to a point seven degree window
left right you just want to educate you
want to pass along the raw evidence
that's right what's happened that's
right and that now make your educated
decision of what you want to do with
this information right and then if you
do want to take action in helping move
forward with decreasing the amount of
carbon that we emit which it's about
eight Giga tons
yeah Carbon predictably we're gonna emit
50 to gigatonnes of carbon dioxide
equivalencies in Twenty twenty Twenty
twenty Twenty twenty to twenty
twenty-one right around there in one
year that's the that's the annual annual
is fifty to give dee-do Gigaton Wow
if we can reduce that and all the
studies say this the White House study
the IPCC study all say that if we can
reduce that 52 to 44 yeah we will have
art the trajectory sufficient to
actually start to decline so that we can
get to zero emissions before we use up
our carbon budget which right now is
going to happen in 15 years okay and
that the car and again the carbon budget
is the what we have as it's kind of like
what is we're able to emit before that
it's like a balloon you can put so much
you know in it and then it explodes
right your pops so you know if we we've
got the budget that we've got is going
to be exhausted in about five
teen years so once once we surpassed
that amount of emissions then we've
guaranteed a future of at least two
degree warming so you know that's the
whole gig now when it came up so it's
got to go down to 44 it's gotta go down
to 40 for her year and then that's right
that would that would neutral the
neutralizes the carbon that's right
that's right
okay so we'd be flatline then in terms
of temperature increasing that's right
bite okay yes so that you know is like a
lot of the pressure here like we were
talking about earlier it's not on the UN
or the government no more so on us as
individually and then entrepreneurs as
well as right the clean energy
attribution the clean meat revolution is
yes one absolutely look and and all the
people that are working on policy and
you know very important and government
legislation and all that but none of its
gonna none of it is going to produce the
impact in the two-year window so that's
why we're focused on that everybody else
you know was absolutely should keep
doing what they're doing but it's the
action that's gonna make the difference
you know it's what's the action
what's the direct action with the
immediate results so you know one of the
things that we've got is we've now got
the 2020 or bust app so you download you
can get at the Google store the Apple
Store and you go in there and depending
on where you live in the world and what
actions you're gonna take you actually
get your 2020 budget so that I can see
okay I didn't you know buy a plastic
bottle today I took the train instead of
drove my car I you know didn't eat that
hamburger today the simple kind of
things that anybody can do I can then
see the impact that that has on my
budget and with everybody else who's got
the app and playing what we call the
game of the century yeah I can see that
I can see the direct impact of my daily
action on our project to actually get us
on track by the end of 2020 to end in
the crisis because we had the other
thing that the ordinary person didn't
have was some way that they could
actually say okay this is the end this
you know it's like trying to play soccer
well you don't know where the goal is
you don't know where the ball is you
don't know how much time you've got it's
impossible it's just this kind of
amorphous thing okay I'll recycling hope
so we put it down
this is what this is you know this is
the end game this is where we are this
is the gap that we've got this what
we've got a bridge and as a global
collective we can actually do it and
it's so it's not it's not just the the
ending the crisis and that's obviously I
mean I think it's you know certainly in
my lifetime the most dire issue you know
the most critical issue but the
opportunity for people to wake up to
I've got the power yep
you know it's not the government it's
not you know and all that stuff is what
you know but government was never set up
to have the power was set up to serve
the people but now it's like if you
listen to people even people you know
because I go to a lot of conferences and
so when my topic is always you know it's
individual action a lot of people think
that individual action is voting or
running for office all of that's
important but in terms of this crisis it
really is gonna be I'm gonna ride my
bike today that produces an actual
result yeah and then you get to actually
see how much carbon you that you didn't
admit that's right I'm making that
choice absolutely absolutely a hamburger
and using plastic bottles right this is
actually that's a good way to empower
people to understand yeah how much their
individual efforts absolutely so then
then I you know it's a different way you
get to live your life then which is wow
what I do to date what I did today
really does matter you know and end it
and that the the action that I take
actually has an impact on you
you know that it isn't this thing like
well if you know it's too bad you live
where you live but you know it's not
happening here so you know we're lucky
you know everybody's in this deal
together we were just at one of the
events for the global climate action and
we saw the Pacific Islanders and the
Pacific Islanders are doing their dance
and there are music yes so beautiful yes
and then
there there are these tens of thousands
of these islands in the Pacific Ocean
yes and they have a hundreds of
thousands of people and yes in there and
there's they were telling me about how
they are he just got kicked off their
island now having brought out ships to
Fiji because their island was mine for
phosphate that's right and and they're
also these little tiny atolls that have
you know just barely that much room you
can feel the ocean breeze on both sides
yep and so that and that doesn't take
that much water increase to just get rid
of those islands right and so these are
really pressing issue oh absolutely you
know and they're you know they're the
you know and I again you know I hear
people you know from the Pacific Islands
right and and they'll say you know you
go back to your office
when this conference is over we go back
to people that have nowhere to live and
nowhere nothing to eat because their
farmland is flooded you know when you
talk about two degrees we're underwater
right and you know and it's it's you
know they're they did the least to bring
this about yeah they're getting
hardest-hit that's right and they have
the least resources to do anything about
it they're not the ones burning massive
amounts of exactly else into the
atmosphere yeah that's right yeah and
they're not the ones that are consuming
that they have the billions of cows yeah
causing tremendous methane emissions
yeah so the clean meat revolution we do
a lot of biotech yes so yeah and so we
love the cool talking about clean
absolutely that seems to be huge because
as you start growing meat and yet IO
reactors yes feeding the world
sustainably pristine sustainably yeah
that's gonna take a huge decrease on
them oh my gosh you know absolutely and
you know and one of the things that
we're you know we have our official
global launch for our kind of two-year
sprint in this deal in the first week in
December and so we've got you know
strategic partners that are lining up
and people that are supporting the whole
thing because we got to get the whole
world in the game and one of our
partners is the Loving Hut you know
which is vegan biggest
of restaurants right and and they have
they have our we have our first vegan
billboard on highway 101 where is it it
I don't know where is on the Santa Clara
yeah so what's this awesome is 2020 or
bust and go be vegan and you know but
it's so cool right and and the the thing
that's great about that people just
again people just don't have any idea
how much water it takes to produce a
hamburger
how many acres of farmland I mean it's
like well the connection the connection
man that you can see that the impact
that that is you know you can it's the
awareness that gives you such an
opportunity to make a difference that
you didn't know you could make yep
and I love how the awareness is such a
key to education is such a key to all of
the different variables that go into
yeah what we experience with our choices
of the hamburger absolutely yeah
and even something like garbage water
bottle waste yeah and and then okay so
what are some of the I think this would
be an interesting question yeah some of
the best resources for kids to best
understand what's going on with climate
action as well as how they're you know
your app is a good way for you to
understand this sure yeah how can they
learn more about it wow let's teach
their kids yeah I don't you know I think
my kids are teaching their parents now
you know kids need to teach their
parents these so first of all I don't
know okay is the answer and what I'll
say about it is is that you know I have
the opportunity to go into lots of
schools because clearly you know the
education system youth major major
driver in this and teaching obedient
workers yes and and I had that was in
Seattle and I was with what couple
things I don't want to say this about
kids because I it's amazing so we're in
this
middle-schooler so the kids were like 9
to 13 something like what that age group
right and so I get there and the
teachers you know meet with the teachers
beforehand and then they said their big
concern was they said please don't scare
the children mm-hmm and I'm like thank
you I mean this I think I liked okay I'm
not gonna go hey let's take a walk
through these be high you know it's like
I wasn't planning on scaring them but I
said but I totally understand not a
problem
you know no not right I don't know how
much I agree with that
anyway Wow yeah I never have any ethical
scaring right like what's gonna happen
with that's right I owe engineering
that's right so just explore actually
that's right right so so how I you know
start when I what I'm what I'm talking
to kids right is that I say so when you
hear the word term global warming what
do you think and just listen to whatever
they say right yeah yeah so you know I'm
there you know and I'm you know the
great thing about kids is they'll you
know they'll just come up as close as
they can do and they're just right on
the floor and they're like you know you
know and adults are like you English but
don't feel like picking the last seat
right and and I so I started up and I
said so you know all right so when you
hear the term global warming you know
what do you think of this you know
adorable must she's about nine years old
right in the front raising her head I
said what she said the apocalypse fusion
I said hey she brought and that I said
so let's just let's deal with that right
and then somebody said well I will are
we really gonna burn to death I mean
these were kid like legitimate questions
that they have right that they walk
around with and and I just said I said
all right so let's just say this if
something really bad was gonna happen
would you want to know exactly what it
was so you could do something about it
or would you want people to pretend that
it wasn't really that bad so that you
feel better they say oh we want to know
what it is and I said great you know and
you lay it out for them in a way but
they understand and then they say okay
good well here's
we're gonna who's gonna do and they come
up with projects and they got class
things and everything but the best thing
about this particular group was that
this doesn't often happen but I enjoyed
it back to talk to the parents group at
the same school and I went in there and
they were just I don't know what you did
to my kid but I can't buy plastic
anymore and he I'm like and it was like
so great right and you know and they
were like somewhat annoyed but pretty
you know but I tell you that um when we
started doing this and you know we got
into the app and everything we had you
know one of the experts we have with
this gamification expert right and he
said your target audience is 12 to 15
year olds and he said that was one of
the most successful campaigns ever done
was he anti-smoking campaign and that's
who they targeted because the parents
can't escape the kid his yeah right no
team comebacks no ill come back are you
still not recycling are you ever and
they have an enormous impact on the
parents and at that age things are very
simple for the kid it's so interesting
so the kids actually have the power
absolutely absolutely so if you target
change action chief campaigns as 12 to
15 year olds yeah and they and they
latch on to yeah to make impact they'll
talk to their parents absolutely their
parents to change yeah and when you and
when you do the math and you know tell
them okay this is the year that you know
25 percent of lower Manhattan is gonna
be underwater they're still alive that's
very different when you talk to people
that are 50 and they've begun yeah yeah
okay so you also hear there's something
important to unpack well first a quick
story as well for your your your
experience with young people Ron and I
were just doing a little quick of video
from our from my phone to the TriCaster
and we were live-streaming it and the
the general idea is we just go out into
the streets and around this neighborhood
and just talk to people from the phone
onto the livestream and when we ran into
this group of kids that were right in
the front hallway and
you know they were here I think they
were doing the escape room thing in the
building but anyway it was this group of
about 13 they're like 17 year old girls
and I was like five or six girls yeah
and and we you know we asked him like
hey what are your thoughts on humanity
like what are you carrying a lot right
now and they're like and they're like
climate you know about climate action
yeah and I was like whoa okay so tell us
about why I care about and they're like
well we care about earth we care about
me yeah so we can live here longer yeah
and I was like whoa this yeah rate yeah
and so then I brought over some of our
some of our friends have you know like
edible up cycled granola bars and I and
some of our other like sustainable food
like cricket chips and stuff like that
yeah a protein yeah anyway I brought
them some of that stuff and then they
were like oh this is so neat so so these
are so interesting here with young
people that cared about that we're
talking to their parents that's all yeah
happening but here's a quick here's a
quick point that I want you to talk on
you you were saying this earlier you
said that if you were diagnosed with
cancer yes you would want to know the
truth that's right and so why would we
not want to know the truth I mean about
climate we want to know the truth I
don't know how we can take action just
like with cancers right we'd want to
know what action we can take to
potentially help ourselves or to spend
our last time doing what we want to do
with our time hopefully not with climate
there's no you can't I'm sure yeah sure
sure yeah well I think you know it's I
don't you know I don't know I mean I'm
not gonna do some Diagnostics or but
there just is whatever that kind of
aversion to the discomfort of it you
know one of the things we say is what if
you had something that everybody needed
to know and nobody wanted to hear yep
right and it is in so in and out you
know it's like I'll go to these it's
like the one percenter the the
counterculture yeah ninety-nine percent
stinking one way you're thinking yeah
the other way but everyone needs to hear
that yeah actually correct yeah and I
you know and I think you know I one of
the you know other things we say is that
you know hope is the opiate of the
powerless and it's like not bad to have
hope okay but if that's a key part of
your strategy
it's a really bad strategy hope in
action yeah but but in and there's this
you know kind of Mythology out there
that you know while do you motivate
people with fear or do you motivate them
with hope well you know action doesn't
come from either one action comes from
action so the thing that we found is
that the key is the opportunity so you
give people like people say well the
information is power information isn't
power you know you find somebody that's
trying to lose weight
there are inability to lose weight isn't
because they don't have that critical
fact called eat less okay but there's a
big difference between having the
information and then taking the action
so we present the information in a way
that it actually is there for someone as
an opportunity to make a difference not
just this is what's happening yeah and
we don't you know we have a you know I
think you know it's funny I go to these
conferences and people say you're here
and you don't have to be here because I
mean you know there are worse things
than dying a climate change and one of
them was go into a climate change
conference and you know I mean it's just
charts and graphs and you know and who's
gonna do that right nobody's gonna do
that the ordinary person is you know
that stuff puts them to sleep so that's
why we came up with the app that's why
we want to be you know pop culture
that's why you want to have it be
engaging fun interesting simple gamified
exactly when you sick are yeah
absolutely absolutely so this is it you
know this is just it this is it
okay so I want to hear your thoughts
about the variables that go that go into
this calculation because there seems to
be you know billions when you look at
your guests when you talk to you please
look at you this yes when you talk or
seem to be there seem to be billions of
variables that need to be calculated in
order to actually all right yeah come up
with a yep a good way of understanding
this so do do we actually take into
account all the variables or like what
variables are going into account here
the parts per million of carbon in the
atmosphere
how are we actually measuring like solar
flare intensities you know are we even
looking that far away at what's going on
with us well first of all let me say
that this was done by people that are
far smarter than me but that I have been
you know fortunate enough to have
working with 20/20 or bust so this was
the scientists and this took about two
years for them you know like that and
they're great scientists so for example
we have you know one of the one of them
was the lead author on the UN EP
emissions gap report which is kind of
the report out there that actually
tracks does scenario planning if we stay
the way we are right now this is where
we're headed if we get aggressive this
is where we're headed if we get you know
this is what happens with the Paris
agreement this is what happens without
the Paris agreement this you know like
that yeah so all that kind of scenario
planning went into effect now did they
take every variable into effect no okay
and you know I there's all kinds of
things like methane explosions in from
the ocean that I don't even know you
know are way outside my that could
definitely happen there's all kinds of
things we didn't take every variable has
not been taken into account however
that's honesty though that's great yeah
however the bulk of what's out there in
terms of the information that's actually
known and that's been verified has been
used so that that that what people have
said and you know and you could go out
our website and get the rationale
document and all the sciences there and
you know verification and you know
studies and all of that what what
everyone what the people that have seen
it have said is you know it's it's not
an exact science but this is sure close
enough to what everybody sees is the way
that it is and that and
overwhelming consensus is and there was
just an article somebody showed me in
the New York Times that we are reaching
what I think they called the tipping
point or what it but but that it's the
window is closing yeah so we're just
gonna wake people up that we got two
years 500 million people 8 gigatons
let's go and then what are some of your
favorite clean energies that are coming
onto the market bicycles is that such a
that's so awesome that you said that
because I was at a meditation retreat
earlier this year yeah and at the
meditation retreat I was told by my
friends that I was meditating with there
they asked me the question they're like
do you think cars are good and I said
well you know cars get you from point A
to point B faster and that you know and
and and these in the knee ask you know
why do you have to get from point A to
point B faster yeah and you know why our
cities organized in the way that they
are that's right and that all these
different questions yeah and he's like
what if everybody was riding a bicycle
how's my time change how would you know
vehicles of the stuff why do you need it
and anyway I thought that was a very
interesting way of just looking at how
we pass time and economics and all yeah
and I mean just that you know and like
you said but I mean a lot of where
people need to go is in a relatively
short distance people who live in the
cities people you know so it isn't like
you you know got to travel 20 miles and
if you have to travel 20 miles obviously
that's gonna you know for most people
that's gonna be a different thing but
you know what doesn't involve engines at
all is awesome yeah okay and it's
healthy it's totally healthy fresh air
your Audi I mean it's just you know it's
great and and so that's okay so bicycles
that's actual that's a really good
answer for clean energy most yeah most
people would say that at first what
about in terms of you know solar wind oh
wow
what do you think out of those is most
promising for our future well I either
solar or wind because they you know
there's because there's there there is
no engine involved I mean it's it's it's
it's just there right it's it is
literally using the energy source that
already exists yep you know so solar and
wind are great absolutely absolutely
photovoltaic is that photovoltaic yeah
yeah I'm smart I was smart not Tom like
everybody says I'm smart you know what
some respects sorry to interrupt you
guys
photovoltaics so those are getting
better those are getting more and more
inside jokes they're getting more and
more efficient over time which is
fantastic yeah you know wind is already
there all this you know I think a lot of
people don't even realize that a
majority of the oxygenation of the
planet comes from phytoplankton from the
ocean mmm seventy percent and that among
30 percent comes from the rainforest
from forestry so I guess once we get
these these like educational you know
numbers and stats and get them and get
that in in the way that you yourself can
make impact absolutely like you're doing
here through that yeah I will guide
people towards these different changes
once clean me come in all these
difference right yep these different
clean energies come in okay so let's ask
you a couple questions that we like to
ask on the show do you have any other
thoughts about about the climate action
that you want to share as well that we
may have not have come now I do I just I
think there's a that that this crisis
presents a real opportunity for humanity
to really re-examine itself yes you know
my mirror you know my what I don't want
to have happen is that there's this huge
I mean and you know not that it would be
bad okay so I don't mean that but you
know we are great at coming up with
these scientific solutions to everything
you know and you look at our society and
you know everybody's got a smartphone
now and we've got you know bombs that
can kill ten you know a hundred times
more people you know in a tenth of the
time that you know we used to be able to
enjoy but then you think but then but
then you look at kind of the quality of
life of people the kind of you know and
it's like we're not progressing and so
in some ways yes in some ways yes but
it's you know how we're doomed it yeah
so so I just you know we just think that
it's a real opportunity for the whole
the way we consume the way we relate
with each other the way we relate to
ourselves the way we relate to the
planet you know I mean it you know it
used to be that you know back before you
know the Europeans got this land which
then became America you know that it was
you know before we make any major
decision we will look seven generations
ahead to see the impact that's really
cool which is awesome right I'm you know
because the earth was was their mother
yes so you wouldn't drill your mother
you wouldn't mind your mother you
wouldn't sell your mother that was like
preposterous yeah yeah but then all of a
sudden here we are and you know we look
to the next corner for their earnings
and what's going to go back to their
shareholders and the earth is just this
resource and you know just very very
wacky what what kind of what it's come
to
you know and and you know if I'm gonna
win you're gonna have to lose a little
and well you know that's okay and that's
you know and it's just crazy crazy crazy
so we just see it as this real
opportunity to rethink all of that and
come out of this not just having averted
you know science fiction time in terms
of the future but that there's a real
shift in terms of humanity itself you
know it's a crisis of consciousness and
responsibility not carbon or politics or
any of the other crap yeah that was so
well said luck on that was that was
eighth grade that was so good
holy cow yeah I just imagine just
hanging out with with just more of us
called the we look
I can culture yeah look back at how we
thought about things and yes like Wow
let's take care of earth this is a
stewardship this is this is how we
behave I am you know and that there's
you know then they named their you know
the children Running Bear cuz you know
it was we were it's all life yeah it's
all connected yeah and to and to take
and to get greedy and it is it's a
distance to disappoint it let's kill him
[Laughter]
see see the interesting thing though Ron
is like you know why you're not taking
me seriously
well you know we can't just like this is
something has to be done other what are
we gonna do just watch why allow them to
destroy our planet yeah we're gonna turn
the other cheek yeah we're gonna forgive
in this sake no no yes right no we're
not
Murder She Wrote you know our hash tag
as this is mine this is mine you know
and that that it's all mine you know the
plan it's mine humanity's mind the
situation is mine that it's not this you
know the good Democrats and the bad
Republicans or the bad oil and it you
know it's like no it's all mine okay
it's all mine I've got something to say
about this and you know these are the
actions that I'm gonna take to actually
express that oh man yeah you're right
it's it's a it's a global increase in
consciousness that's happening over the
next absolute level decades and and it's
and it's it's really beautiful to see it
in young kids in their eyes right that's
right and their passion and we're here
for these two years so they've got those
decades yeah okay awesome that was so
that was a really great way to to talk
about what what's what's perfect thank
you Ron little timer oh my gosh that's
right out of the Wizard of Oz it is
right
yeah
quiet you clinking Clank why my little
darlings fly okay so so as we are
increasing our consciousness there seem
to be a lot of other pressing issues
that are going on around the planet yep
as well yep
we we talk about this a lot on the show
we see like artificial intelligence and
biotechnology and nanotechnology there's
all these things that are kind of
evolving out into the planet yep that we
don't really have a there's no parental
supervision right with any of these ends
yeah so where do you see kind of these
the evolution are you do you see things
you know realistically optimistically
pessimistically how do you see them I
see them as important but I've we've got
two years that's you everything else is
everything else and not that it's less
more anything like that but this two
years everything is in the balance we
have a question from one of our viewers
yes yes let's hear the question yes just
asks what are the top three ways the
public can do to prevent what's
happening right now yeah that's part of
your yeah yeah not the number one action
that the ordinary person is is to reduce
your beef intake reduce the beef intake
so well you know if you you you it's you
know it's it's I think it's that if
every family in America would simply
reduce one of their beef meals a week
it's the equivalent of something like
getting 500,000 cars off the road and
again it could be numbers a little bit
off it but it's a dramatic in terms of
the effect
and you know that that that you know
most of the amount of farmland that is
used only for industrial farming you
know simply to grow cattle I mean it's
just the knockoff effect you know the
water that's used absolutely the water
that's used absolutely the food that's
used yeah yeah and it really is a matter
of consciousness that when you just
start looking around and seeing you know
as I go through my day not to do some
radical thing and they're gonna people
that go radical something's gonna go
totally vegan and we love the radicals
okay but everybody's not gonna do that
but everybody can look around their day
and when they go to the store and you
know taking a bag to the store instead
instead of taking the one that's there
you know we're using something getting a
you know getting a reusable water bottle
instead of all the plastic that you're
gonna you know unbelievable the impact
that that makes right yes yes you know
the in New York I live in New York the
amount of plastic that's used in take
out ridiculous right yeah yeah so we've
got campaigns about that you know so
it's it's when you look out and see what
you're doing and the the small seemingly
small change that you can make that on a
daily basis what it adds up to is quite
remarkable remarkable okay so these
little action items seem to be you seem
to be huge we're more what was number
three
reduced beef intake reduced plastic use
and what else well your transportation
definitely makes a difference in
transportation you have to buy huge yeah
yeah I like how you're making everything
that is that's what seemingly small seem
really impactful yes and now that and
that's that's really huge
I actually am still upset that we
haven't transitioned to biodegradable
Xin everything every song packaging yes
because we have the technology it's just
about the the ink is the increase in a
couple pennies per I don't which is
where I not the couple pennies per item
right no no don't write that out of the
earnings that's right
yeah cuz yeah that's [ __ ] it is
total total [ __ ] you can say [ __ ] on
your you can swear
I've been I've been completely like
[ __ ] yeah that's all sure exactly oh
my god
humanity is bullshitting itself into
oblivion that's one of the things I saw
that post yeah you can say that we're
[ __ ] ourselves oh my god
so oh so or so you seem very you're very
focused on climate action that's not
really important yes but at the same
time there are so many other issues do
you feel as though that the other issues
deserve like artificial intelligence
ethics or biotech ethics do you think
that those also deserve an equal amount
of attention yeah I think I I I do okay
I do and one of the hopes that I now one
of the what I want okay or what what
we're out for with 2020 or bust is that
whatever the issue is that people have a
greater sense of their own power in
dealing with whatever it is yeah you
know that if we can if we make this
thing happen with the climate you know
what else can we do yeah you know that
we've stopped leaving it up to somebody
else that nobody's coming that nobody's
gonna save us that it isn't some great
leaders job to make it all better for us
that this is our deal yeah yeah I like
that I don't look for leaders to guide
us out of this they're the ones that are
putting us in this mess the whole Bureau
too bureaucratic OPA litical systems
yeah we are the leaders you know yeah I
mean what you're doing what you're doing
here I mean this is amazing
it's a little bit a little more travel
is amazing but this is pretty good would
be yes that's you got you got me on that
one
so okay so I like how you painted this
picture of us figuring out climate
action and then being able to figure all
these other cuz yeah we kind of realize
our own divinity and power within
ourselves to take on these actions and
then we can work on all these other
challenging issues together moving
forward I like that you know and and to
make it measurable make it actionable
put it in time not someday doing our
best
let's stay optimistic you know no I mean
these are this is reality we're in it's
it's a real planet it's real people it's
real carbon it's real time yeah it's
really happening
yep yep okay couple quick questions on
the way all right first one is do you
think we're alone in the cosmos oh my
gosh
no I I can't you know no I mean I think
it's a pretty cool place but III don't
know I have no idea of knowing but if I
was gonna bet I'd say no we're not alone
and then do you think that do you think
that now but I don't know what the not
alone looks like I don't think there's
somewhere else that people are sitting
doing an interview like this you don't
think so no no okay okay no okay
interesting although your shirt is
awesome right yeah yeah they're doing an
interview right they're acting exactly
right yeah yeah so but I do think there
is whatever whatever that would be
somewhere else that is whatever that
life is I do you know know I gotta ask
for this talking because I've really
been diving deeper into this sort of
like metaphysics uh-huh so I asked do
you think that the do you think that you
are in this flesh vehicle or do you
exist somewhere else when did this
question come up well you wouldn't say
that again I don't know I don't I don't
relate to myself
as limited in the skin bag good skin
back a few yeah you're not limited to
the skin bag so what what Deann the skin
bag gets me around they get you around
so you know you like you know so where
where do where do you where do you live
a quick westward you live outside of the
skin bag and how do you transcend this
skin bag that's none of your goddamn
business I live in the world yeah I
really that this is you know I'm of the
world for the world in the world and you
know part of what's in the world is my
piece uh-huh okay deep now do you think
that this is a base reality or do you
think that you are in a base in us or is
this a similar one I know I I don't know
what I'm not familiar with base reality
so I know I just don't never heard that
I don't know so if you were if you were
just able to design your own virtual
world and enter it and here you are oh
you know 40 years later you're in this
virtual world and you are who you are oh
you know you're playing this virtual
game for 80 years in this world and the
next one you get to go to whatever other
virtual world what would you do you
think that this is a base reality or do
you think this is a virtual one you
simulated what do you mean life on Earth
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know okay
and I think it's fun to you know I did
hear a theory that I enjoyed okay so I
don't know but I but one theory I heard
that I did enjoy was that that to all of
the life forces in the whatever cosmos
okay earth is a very hot ticket ah
I have heard that diagnosis because you
get to feel pain love heartbreak loss
ecstasy joy it's got all these like
you know right so it's like a hot ticket
okay
and I like that there's no idea that has
anything to do with the way it actually
is there anything but you don't seem
cool to me right like I thought yeah
this is a pretty cool you know yeah yeah
we're now we're we're and how great you
that we're for the first time you know
at least that I know of is is that a
species is actually extinguishing itself
and it has the capacity to be aware of
what it's doing doing yeah yeah but the
question is will it wake up in time yeah
so it's a pretty awesome adventure yeah
yeah so it's a hot ticket for the wide
range of emotion and then it's also hot
ticket cuz it's like will they translate
that well a week oh my god looking like
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting I like
that one no we've been here we've been
hearing that creeping into our lives -
so it's cooling okay because maybe on
these other player ox orbiting stars
maybe in there's other virtual worlds
the tickets just not as hot it's just no
yeah you know I mean you know maybe you
just have like you know romance
paperbacks or something you know you
know I don't know or you know
shuffleboard or you know what you got
here right last question oh okay okay
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world love and tell us why
because it's love it's just love what
does it make what does it make you feel
that you know it's it's
when everything else falls away what's
there is love hmm that's so beautiful
thank you yeah thank you you're very
welcome that's I love it I love your
questions thank you that was a really
good answer
I felt everything falling away yeah it's
like love right there Oh such a good so
profound thank you yeah thank you for
coming on to our shop you're so thank
you
all right knock that [ __ ] off
what a pleasure everyone thank you very
much for tuning in if you guys had a
good time definitely give us a comment
below let us know your thoughts go check
out 20/20 or bust or the link download
the app 20/20 or bus yes the download
the app 20/20 or bust links in the bio
go check that out take these little
action items that you can do they
actually make a big impact and actually
go see and become a part of the movement
join the family subscribe let us know
your thoughts also don't just consume
this content go and create go and start
your own blog go start your own videos
go and make some business into the world
go and execute everyone and thank you
Ron our producer director Thank You
Jeremy and Lachlan this has been such a
pleasure guys thank you thanks everyone
and we'll see you soon
peace